bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france beaucoup de réactions après la
validation par le parlement du retour de
ces néonicotinoïdes la gauche notamment
évoque un recul environnemental on
imagine que vous partager ce point de
vue oui c'est ça c'est une totale
régression quand on voit qu aux etats
unis on a réussi à supprimer 12
néonicotinoïdes l'année dernière nous en
2008 en france on en a supprimé 3 et au
final on fait une marche arrière par le
biais des lobbys encore une fois
agrochimique et agro-industriel bien on
a du souci à se faire pour l'écologie en
france
enfin moi ça ne me portent beaucoup de
peine l'utilisation des néonicotinoïdes
avait tété a initialement interdite en
septembre 2018 dans le cadre de la loi
de reconquête de la biodiversité à voter
là aussi par le parlement et pour
protéger les colonies d'abeilles en
déclin comment est ce que vous expliquez
aujourd'hui ce revirement
mais comme je vous dis c'est le poids
des lobbys c'est encore une fois
l'économie
il y à des solutions alternatives alors
les betteraviers bien évidemment
puisqu'ils sont poussés à voir de plus
en plus de surfaces agricoles
ils ont du mal à se défaire de ces
pesticides et puis de lutter contre les
pucerons et la jaunisse par exemple par
contre en agriculture biologique on
arrive à trouver des alternatives qui
fonctionne simplement le gouvernement ne
l'êtes pas assez à la transition
agricole et ça depuis depuis très
longtemps on le dit toutes les
associations le 10 et au niveau des
financements de ceux de ces aides
il ya énormément de solutions qui sont
proposées par exemple en ce moment il ya
le le rapporteur général du budget
européen pierre larrouturou qui
actuellement grève de la faim parce
qu'il propose justement dans le cadre du
green new deal une taxe sur les sur les
spéculateurs par exemple on pourrait
aussi imaginer une taxe sur les gros
pollueurs sur le bronze industriel tout
ça n'est pas fait et on préfère donner
des avantages à certains agriculteurs et
qui sait si demain il y aura pas les
céréaliers ou les producteurs de maïs
qui qui réclameront également ce genre
davantage on sait pas ce qu'il peut se
passer donc donc voilà voilà les raisons
simplement économique c'est une guerre
de lobby et envoie que la santé publique
et le
la destruction des espèces d insectes
n'importe peu quels sont les risques
aujourd'hui d'utilisation des
néonicotinoïdes et quelques ailes
quels ont été les résultats de l'inter
de leur interdiction en 2018
il ya eu une baisse de l'impact sur les
abeilles malheureusement pas suffisant
et surtout le gros problème c'est que
les insectes pollinisateurs
il contribue à 75% de la pollinisation
de l'agriculture vivrière
donc on voit que les pollinisateurs sont
très très importante c'est le cas
également qu'ils nourrissent les oiseaux
donc tout ça ça entraîne des décès sur
les insectes et sur les oiseaux en 25
ans il ya une baisse de 75 % de la
biomasse des insectes sais pas si vous
vous rendez compte
alors on peut se dire ouais c'est juste
des insectes que tout est lié et nous
les humains on va en subir les
conséquences de tout ça puis en plus on
trouve des néonicotinoïdes dans nos
assiettes et dans le 75 % des pots de
miel dans le monde et des études qui le
prouvent
donc c'est très très grave c'est pas
juste une question d'abeilles et en plus
ces nuits aussi aux apiculteurs qui sont
également des agriculteurs alors on le
rappelle pour l'instant il s'agit d'une
dérogation temporaire qui va donc avoir
cours jusqu'en 2023
et c'est ce que vous nous dites
aujourd'hui vous vous redoutez que
d'autres filières se manifeste aussi
pour obtenir de telles dérogations mais
il se manifeste déjà et ils obtiendront
certainement des dérogations site ça le
problème avec cette politique c'est
qu'on va donner des avantages aux uns et
aux autres donc ça va créer des petits
conflits internes et puis finalement ça
ça va aller en escalade comme ça et puis
qu'est ce qui va se passer à l'avenir
que je veux dire là c'est vraiment un
retour en arrière au lieu d'avancer au
lieu d'aider vraiment une transition
écologique je parle pas d'une écologie
punitive
et pas question culpabiliser les
agriculteurs et d'ailleurs c'est pas
parce que je suis écolo que je vais
voter yannick jadot je préfère le dire à
ceux qui me regardent pas ce que souvent
on fait l'amalgamé c'est pas ça c'est
accompagné des agriculteurs dans une
transition biologique tout à fait
possible plein plein de deux
d'alternative par exemple honte et de
l'avoine ça peut permettre de faire
baisser le risque de pucerons etc
genis il ya aussi les insectes c'est un
comble d'ailleurs les insectes qui vont
se nourrir
des pucerons sont tués par les
néonicotinoïdes donc c'est un cercle
vicieux dont il faut se défaire
absolument merci beaucoup à almaty
coderre a pris le temps de réagir sur
notre antenne